quand que je n'ai pas l'assurance que ça
peut se faire en toute sécurité
je ne tiens pas rouvrir c'est à dire que
le conseil d'état a le conseil d'état
revient sur un sur une demande du
gouvernement se met maintenant est-ce
que ce qu'est ce qu'elle est le point de
vue des scientifiques du personnel
médical est ce qu'il est vraiment temps
d'ouvrir un doublé ses lieux de culte
pour que pour que les fidèles puissent
revenir en toute sécurité et sans et
sans affecter d'autres ou à voir on va
voir des personnes malades dans mesure
où la pratique du culte on la continue
puisque chacun l'a fait chez soi dès
qu'ils ont plus question de vue des
finales peuvent m'appeler me demander de
renseignement des informations donc pour
l'instant et avons continué à se faire
alors bien sûr chacun chez soi